[Music]
foreign
and it becomes all you know let's thank
God for the food y'all I bought the food
George Foreman ain't no new champ he's
down
who said that
you wanna say nothing George
God stop because he was dead
I was
I'm done I'm not going to box anymore do
you know what you're walking away from
so I want to spread the word of God and
what I saw
for you it's hard hard I've been getting
punched in the face
sometimes it feels about the same hey
enjoy yourself
power company said we never paid the
bill really
two things I know how to do that's box
who preach and preaching won't pay the
bills
you made me some money doc you can do it
again
it is my destiny to win the heavyweight
championship belt again
last time they saw me I looked like
Superman and now you look like a mission
in there this ain't no beauty contest
Michael Moore he's 26 and Unstoppable
how can you beat that man
it's young man's game
let's go
now
sniff
[Music]
Mr Foreman that funny little Grill deal
you signed is starting to generate some
substantial checks really now I'm just
surprised it shows a big old fat guy
like me to sell a beer to help people
get lean
[Music]
foreign